Hi, Orlando.
Alright, well.
How are you?
But that's fine, a little bit busy.
No.
Typical Mohti.
Yep.
I think Lewis is on hold, so is Lewis joining back or we are good to start?
Yeah.
Yeah, he will send him back.
S.
Perfect.
But just I think this is our first connect that we are having Orlando Weekly.
Mhm.
And I just want to see how the trainings are going on, how Santiago is going on, any feedback, how things are going on on your side with Santiago.
Okay, so basically the last two weeks he was working directly with me. So practically, according, of course, of the plan that we designed for specifically for him, he's doing good. He's doing very good.
Right now, he's practically taking a couple of the tests that was assigned to him without any kind of issue or problem. He practically easily handled it.
So, for now, in of course, in my opinion, according to my evaluation,
I think that he is doing good.
From our side, there is a couple of inconvenience related to the to the platform that we normally work or we supposed to train him to.
To work with us, uh, but that's...
That was not an issue during the...
During the jobs that I'm assigning to him.
So, basically, at this moment, I can, I can say with...
With all my my secure that he's doing good.
Thank you, Orlando. This really helps. And I know he's also sharing daily or weekly updates with Kip and the team. So we do notice that he's helping with the upgrade activities right now. I think he started with a few of those tasks, right? Patch management and all those.
other than doing the training, right? He already started few of the tasks.
Well, we started batch management last week. I gave some trainings about how we work with the batch management. Practically,
The one of the issue was related to to the platform that we one of the platform that we use for for make the patch management, so we're still handling that, but taking out the the process of the patch management is working more directly with Nutanix right now.
So he practically help us to operate several clusters that we have skills for.
Got it.
or upgrade in the next weeks. So he helped me to practically reduce all this time of the outbreak. And also he helped us to solve several alerts in those clusters.
Right.
So practically, it's working more in deep in Nutanix in the last two weeks compared to the patch management. Keeping in mind that the patch management is something that we normally execute monthly. It's not something that we're doing weekly or several times on the week.
Yeah.
Uh, so...
For now, I understand that he's doing good and he's doing according to our expectations.
Sounds good.
Ashish, Amit, anything or Kip, anything you want to cover?
Yeah, sure. So, yeah.
This is our first interaction. So yeah, Orlando and Luis, nice to meet you. I think this is the first time we're interacting. I'm Amit Dubey. I'm a service delivery manager here at ITBD Design and Ashish and Kip. We are part of the same team, so I'm responsible for the services that we offer.
Yeah.
from our site, we'll be working very closely with you, ensuring that you continue to see the value from the Engineering, and they're aligning with your business requirements and delivering to your expectations. So nice to meet you both.
Nice to meet you.
Thank you. Yeah, back to you, Ashish.
Thank you. So, hi, Orlando and Luis once again. So, as you got a quick intro from Amit, so my name is Ashish, working with IT by Design, the senior technical team lead. So, I have to cheque on the progress of Santiago, how he had been working.
performing and if there is anything that you need assistance with in terms of service delivery or anything in terms of his availability to meet the expectations that he want. So the whole intent of having these service calls is to cheque if engineer is meeting the expectations.
there are any gaps. The measure that we want to proceed, want to work on is proactive, so that if anything that we can uncover in the early stage, we can quickly go ahead and fix it so that we have a long-term relationship with you and IT by Design.
So I would like to quickly go ahead and share my screen. I have a quick presentation deck where I have a couple of data points to be presented from Santiago. At the same time, there are a few
action item that I need to discover, cheque with you and see how we can collectively work towards it. So let me know once you're able to see my screen.
Good.
Yeah, yeah, um, let me see the screen now.
Thank you.
I can see a screen yet.
Thank you. So this is the first slide of our weekly business review. The reiteration we have chosen is June 16th till June 20th. And I'll quickly cover the agenda items for today, which will remain same for all upcoming Connects that we have in future. We would have the check-in.
This will cover how things are moving with the engineer. Highlights, this is where we'll cover the positive impact engineer has made in the previous week or the past two weeks. Action tracker, if there are any items that we need to work on. Performance analysis, this is where we cover
engineers, ticket numbers, their utilization, how they are capturing the work that they are doing into the time entries. Voice of the customer, this is where we cover if we have any specific feedback for the engineer. Way forward, this is where we cover what proactive measures Addy by Design is taking.
to ensure engineer is set up for success. And a recap, as it says, what we covered in the previous connect.
You might not have information in every slide that we'll go through, but I would like to give you a quick glimpse as the time would progress. We would have more information, more data points from Santiago, how it's performing. We will be able to populate some data and we can have a quick collective discussion on the data points.
Any questions so far?
No, for now we're good.
Thank you.
Love it.
Right, how are things at this moment? We have already covered this slide. So Santiago is performing well. He is working on the given projects and the patching tasks. So things are going well as per the feedback that we have received.
Okay, so these are some of the highlights. This will also cover the work that Santiago had performed in the past two weeks, starting with his start date. So Santiago was onboarded on June 8th, where he was first introduced to internal training, planning and how tools and processes work.
and then turn into CP Corp. Last week, Santiago focused on onboarding knowledge transfer and tool familiarisation while taking ownership of operational responsibilities. This is what we have received on the basis of our connect with Santiago every day. We ensure that we know what things engineers are working on.
so that we ensure that things are going in the right direction. A couple of points in terms of his upgrades that he has performed from Prism Central for one of the clients. He also worked on Disaster Recovery Prism Central and DPRE upgrade for
Same client AMC.
He investigated and resolved the multiple upgrade related issues before encountering a prison related network issue. So this is just the overall what he has done in the past two weeks. And I believe we are in the process of changing his shift timing as well as his week offs.
So as per our connect, his shift timings as per Atlantic Central Time would be 9pm to 6am, which is 6.30 to 3.30 as per Indian Time, and week off would be Wednesday and Thursday as per Atlantic Standard Time.
Yep.
Rick.
Thank you. I'll move on to the next slide. This is where we have the action tracker. So the 30, 60, 90 days plan, I think this was shared when Rick completed the onboarding. And so Rick, I'm not sure if we have received the 30, 60, 90 days plan for Santiago.
Yeah, I think we just finalised the one we were using, the standard one, just following that that that that as a standard 30-60-90.
No, I mean, did we receive the failed copy? Like, what?
No, no, no, that's still waiting.
Rick.
All right. So Luis, Orlando, we rely on you to get that information because if there is anything that we find and which will help Santiago to get better at his deliverables, we will internally work with Santiago to ensure that he does what he's expected to.
Mhm.
So the 30, 60 to 90 days plan will give us a roadmap, like how things looks like for Santiago for next 90 days. And if there is any input required from ITBD designs, and we will ensure that we do.
Okay.
Thank you. Next we have is reports to be scheduled for the KPIs. Let me quickly go to the next slide where we have the KPIs, the recommended KPIs from IT by design. These KPIs might sound generic because this is
what we have came up with as per our years of learning and working with multiple partners across different geographies. So engineers like Santiago working at such capacity, we expect them to be at least 80% billable, although this metric is not something that he can achieve from.
first or second week. This will take some time for him to gradually get there, but this is where we want him to be. So are we aligned that billable utilisation for Santiago to be 80% as he progresses?
Right.
I'm sorry, I didn't.
So Orlando, just one thing I wanted to confirm, right? And again, you may have had a conversation already with Rick. So this is just a recommendation from us, not necessarily that these are the KPIs that you need to have with for Santiago, right? Because this is something that may not be completely aligned with your business needs and you may not want to track it or probably do not have a mechanism of tracking it.
Yes.
So the idea of presenting these KPIs as a best practise that we probably can follow for a standard rule, but ideally the kind of rule that he's following right now, right, which is into patching, which is more of a complex work, it'll be ideal to have.
Yeah.
something more customised which completely aligns with this current role in the business. So do you have anything internally that you follow for your internal engineers that you can share with us or would you want to go with a new set of KPIs? How in which direction do you want to go?
The way that we evaluate or for taking the example of the of the job that Chauhan is doing is based in the task that we are going, we are assigning the average of all those tasks.
Mmh.
Mhm.
can take him sometimes more than 8 hours. So that means that probably he will be one day and a half doing or accomplish that. The rest of the tasks that he normally are working, there's related to alerts that was
Uh, presented during the upgrade process in the cluster of Das, so.
Mm.
The way that we evaluate that is depending about what he's doing in the during the week related to the task or ticket that will be assigned. Right now, the next month, he will he will going to start with a specific assignments.
related to the tactics and real work. So I believe that probably starting the next month, I will get more accurate data about the performance in some tasks related to a specific assignments.
Mhm.
Okay.
To to him.
Yeah.
But for now, like I said before, according to all the tickets that he was assigned or that I assigned to him, he's doing according to our expectations.
Mhm.
That's the that's part of the information that I can give to you.
Okay.
No, that is great. Glad to hear that he is meeting expectations. And in future, will you have a mechanism of measuring his performance, Orlando? I mean, it is not necessarily that we need to solve it now. Even if we want to drop us a quick note to let us know what all KPIs that you want to measure for him.
We're more than happy to incorporate it. The only thing that we would need help with is you helping us with that reporting mechanism. So for instance, billable utilisation or total utilisation is what I understood from what you just described, right? That you give him a task and that probably can take up to 8 hours, billable, non-billable, both.
Mmh.
So that could be one of the KPIs. It could be the number of patching that he completes in a day, right? Number of escalations that he deals with in a day. It completely depends on what parameters he want to measure him.
It.
So...
Okay.
OK, yeah, yeah.
Kip.
All right.
Hoh.
Thank you. Back to you, Ashish.
I have a follow-up question. Yep, thank you. I have a follow-up question on this one, Orlando. So is Sushant required to complete 8 hours? So we'll say end of the day. Let's say if you could work on like 6 1/2 hours on patching and other billing activities, is he required to enter 1 1/2 hour additionally to complete 8 hours, or is there something that he can continue with 6.5?
At this moment, yeah, he's practically doing the stuff during his hour or something. He shows that he's...
is available to contribute to other stuff, but I always try, you know, to...
Roll over all the tasks to the to the next shift, because we don't we don't really want the.
The excess of time when we do that with all technicians, we always avoid trying to leave a technician working more than 8 hours necessarily. So practically,
Uhh...
During the during the eight hours, he he's doing the stuff.
And if something was pending, he will...
He told me, he told me that, hey, there's this pending task and I easily can move the task to the next shift.
What?
So, yeah, practically, that's the way that I work with him.
Right. One more thing I wanted to ask, since Shashank is fairly new to the system. And so do we have someone within CP Corps team who is there to assist him if he's stuck anywhere process-wise or
could not find any information within the tools.
Well, practically, the only few guys that he will refer in case that he needs any kind of assistance is me or Lisa D.
We are our direct escalation to him. Apart of that, there's the platform manager, but normally he will need to consult first with us and we can move to the platform manager. So
Alright.
That's the way that we work.
And actually, Luis and I, we're adding our rotation on code. So practically, he always can count with me or Luis.
OK.
I got it.
Thank you.
Okay, so rest of the slides, they do not have any information, so I have unshared my screen.
Any other point of Orlando Luis you have for us?
Wolframing.
Right. Lee, anything from your site?
Thank you, Rose.
Yeah, it's frozen fully.
Yep.
Yeah, what is that?
That's a lot of attention. Yeah, no, we are, we are, we are good. Of course, nice to meet you, Luis and Orlando. Looking forward to working with you. And of course, we've seen you pretty much. You guys are very active on Team chat, et cetera. So yes, just one last thing before we drop. Is this going to be a fixed?
Katarmal.
shift timing for Sushant or is he expected to change to a different shift in future?
For now, according of course of the operation that we have now, that will be his fixed chip for now. Not sure, of course, not sure, everything depending according to our operation, but I understand that
Okay.
Probably until...
I guess until something changed or something big changing our operation, that that will be is just for now.
Mhm.
Sure, sure, OK.
Thank you, Orlando. I think we're all set. And of course, we will reconnect next week. And in the interim, Rick may get in touch with you regarding the KPI discussions, because of course, that's going to be very important. That's how we measure the success and the value addition that they're doing into an environment. So.
You're welcome.
You know, that's something that we will carry forward as a part of our discussion. Rest, I think we're good for now.
Yep.
Okay, got it.
Haight.
Right. So it was nice meeting you, Luis, Orlando. Thank you so much for your time. We will meet next week. Until then, take care of yourself. Thank you. Thank you, Orlando. Thank you, Luis. Bye.
Thank you.
Take care, everyone.
Thank you. Bye.
Thank you, see you guys.
Thank you all.